hey guys Ryan right here today I'm gonna
be going over my top 10 favorite movies
of 2014 right off the bat I want to
establish that this is my list I haven't
seen every movie of the year but from
the movies I've seen these have become
my favorites if your movies are not on
this list no reason to call me a [ __ ]
just understand you have your opinion
and I have my opinion simple as that
for starters number 10 I would have to
say Captain America the Winter Soldier
Captain America the Winter Soldier was
way better than the first one it's a
great like spy espionage thriller I
really like Chris Evans performance as I
like Anthony Mackie I thought there was
a lot of clever things about it the
Winter Soldier villain could have been
developed a little bit more but other
than that it was a fantastic Marvel film
and I think it's one of the better ones
and one of the more dark serious ones
number 9 guardians of the galaxy if you
want to talk about pure entertainment
guardians of the galaxy is the one it is
filled with a ton of action visuals
fantastic acting and Rocket Raccoon has
got to be my favorite character of the
year and not to mention it's the
funniest Marvel movie we've ever had
number eight would have to be Noah I've
seen a lot of different interpretations
of the Noah story I've even read the
comic book Bible at one point in my life
that's how educated I am and I saw the
Jon Voight version Evan Almighty
whatever this film I thought was a great
character driven piece it had a haunting
atmosphere it felt like a fresh take on
the Noah story offered new things to it
I know they added some stuff but it was
it worked in the film the performances
were great Darren Aronofsky's direction
was awesome he it managed to still honor
its religious themes without being
preachy about it darren aronofsky you
know how to depress people I'm so proud
of you number seven would have to be
gone girl if you don't like your spouse
this is the movie for you I like my
spouse so I couldn't completely relate
but it's a good film Ben applix
fantastic David Fincher has his awesome
direction again with a great
cinematography backing it up most
important to me Rosamund Pike best
performance from an actress I've seen
all year was one of the best
performances I've seen in
general male and female they are equal
number six would have to be John wick
that's a character-driven action piece
you know I mean it's not like a [ __ ] ton
of character but there's just enough
it's a welcome return for Keanu Reeves
it's one of his better performances the
action in it is awesome and the criminal
underworld I thought was very unique I
loved the Continental it was an awesome
[ __ ] film to watch and it was funny
hands down one of the best times I had
at the theaters and features some of the
best kills of the year number five would
have to be the raid to Baron doll or
Brandel or whatever it's an Indonesian
action film I loved the first raid the
second one blew me away it took what was
like a 90-minute action movie and then
with the sequel expanded it into like
the reminds me of The Dark Knight how
they had like a story about Batman and
they took the Dark Knight made it a
crime ensemble and that's what this one
did it made it a crime ensemble there's
a lot of story in it a lot of dialogue
but when the actions there it's more
motivated than ever because of the story
that are providing and the story was
great and the action everyone knows if
you've seen the first raid or even just
the fight scene it is very unique still
very violent and beautiful to look at at
the same time Ray two would have to be
one of the best action films I've ever
seen number four would be the lego movie
instantly like while watching this film
I knew it was gonna be one of my
favorite animated movies ever I didn't
have too much anticipation for it but
while I was watching it couldn't believe
it it's incredibly inventive beautiful
to look at and it's really [ __ ] funny
like you'll have a great time watching
it it's like cinematic escape as an
escape azzam escapism at its best number
three would have to be x-men Days of
Future past
x-men 2 is still my favorite x-men movie
but right behind it would have to be
x-men Days of Future past I know it's
some people's favorite overall I really
admire this film a lot I respect what it
accomplished so much you got this dream
ensemble together and there was so much
pressure behind it but in you which
characters to really focus on and the
characters that didn't get as much focus
they still got their time to shine and
it was just a fantastic fun film and it
had some
rises by the time it ended it was a
great way to revamp the series you know
how can you forget Quicksilver man Evan
Peters he's great he's so good he's
great at playing creepy people in
American Horror Story so that's a plus
number two would have to be dawn to the
Planet of the Apes I love this film I
considered it being my number one but at
the end of day it's number two number do
the Apes are all CGI but I [ __ ]
bought it the whole time I was never
distracted the ape characters were all
[ __ ] great the companionship of the
humans and the Apes and then the humans
versus the Apes like it's a story not
about good and bad it's a story just
about survival like all these characters
believe they're doing what's right for
them it's a fantastic [ __ ] film and
it has the prequel ingredient that I
admire most which is you know the
outcome of the end of this story like
you know the aging and [ __ ] winds go
Planet of the Apes but you completely
are not aware of that while you're
watching this film
you're just engrossed in everything
that's going on that you kind of don't
even want the outcome you know that's
going to happen you kind of don't want
it to happen and it's so cool when a
prequel manages to accomplish that x-men
in first class
did that with the x-men series I feel
like dawn of the Planet of the Apes did
that for the Planet of the Apes series
number one right after I was done
watching it I was pretty much certain it
was gonna be my number one movie edge of
tomorrow it is the definition of
cinematic escapism I can't [ __ ] say
escapism today sure entertainment it is
just a [ __ ] blast I love movies that
just make you just have a great [ __ ]
time you know it's a sci-fi story I love
sci-fi I still feel sci-fi is underrated
because that's when writing is really at
its most inventive is sci-fi or fantasy
you're going through a complete fiction
and the sci-fi in it it's great the
action is fantastic the visuals are
great to look at great direction
awesome writing the cinematography was
excellent everything about it it was a
very inventive story too and the
performances by Tom Cruise and Emily
Blunt were awesome number one thing I
really admire about this film actually
was that it was real
funny I wasn't expecting it to be funny
and the funny stuff doesn't distract it
doesn't seem out of place for this film
it actually adds to the film a lot and
there's some great twists and turns the
ending still kind of confused about but
still it's a fantastic film hands down
number one favor film of the year anyway
guys there's other films I noted to make
the list that I gather some ones I was
cosplaying like Godzilla neighbors How
to Train Your Dragon - even Robocop very
underrated film that's my top ten that I
narrowed it down to what is your guys
top 10 list them below and let me know
it's a ripoff of Jeremy John's who says
comment below let me know I'm gonna say
list them below and let me know
Jeremy stealing if you guys are new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects we got a lot of [ __ ] on
here and all these movies I've actually
done reviews on so you can check out my
straight to-the-point show and on our
trailer reaction review show we're gonna
be doing shoutouts again so go to
facebook.com slash the real reject
shoutouts where you can earn yourself a
shout out from this hunky dunky hung
like a monkey's giant cousins